GARY A. HAUGEN:
Well, I didn't plan
to come to Google to get
razzed about my hair,
but I guess you just
don't know what to expect.
So thanks for keeping
me on my toes, Justin.
Thank you all for
joining me today.
It's a great privilege
to get to be here.
I would like to share a
little bit about the problems
of violence in the
developing world,
but I like to start with
a story from Oregon,
the State of Oregon.
And maybe some of
you are joining us
from Northern
California might relate.
So there's this young
woman just a few months ago
who's home alone in her house.
She lives in a rural area,
and just a few months before,
actually, she had been
horrifically assaulted
by this guy.
And this guy is now at
her house, actually.
It's a weekend night.
She's alone, it's
dark, and this guy's
actually tearing his
way into her house.
And she does what
anyone else would
do, she picks up to the
phone to call 911, right?
And then what
proceeds to happen is
the 911 operator engages this
very, very tense conversation
where she explains to this
young woman that I'm sorry,
but because of budget
cuts in your area,
you don't have law
enforcement in your area.
That there's no one that
we can send for you.
Law enforcement was
available on the weekdays,
but this was the weekend.
And there's this
incredibly painful
10 minutes of conversation
where this 911 operator realized
there's just nothing that
she can do for this woman.
And horrifically,
of course, the man
did make his way into the house,
horrifically assaults her,
and rapes her.
And this story did sort of
make the news around the world,
and the reason I
share it, though,
is because this is an
example of what billions
of poor people in the world
live in as their daily reality.
Why is that?
Because they don't have law
enforcement in their area.
A recent UN study found that
about four billion people
in the world live outside
the protection of law.
And one of things we're
trying to do in this book,
"The Locust Effect" is first of
all, get the news of this out.
And then have us pause
together to think
about that for a moment.
What if billions, especially
of the poorest people
in the world, don't have access
to basic law enforcement?
What does that look like?
Well, we know a
bit what it feels
like because of this
story of this woman.
But it looks like something
different in Bolivia,
for instance, where according
to statistics, if you sexually
assault a child in
Bolivia, you actually
are at greater risk of
slipping in the shower
and dying than you are of
actually being convicted
for that crime.
And as a result, there just
an epidemic of sexual violence
against women and
girls in Bolivia.
In India, amazingly,
if you enslave someone
you have a greater chance
of being struck by lightning
than ever being actually
convicted for that crime.
So this is what it looks like
in the developing world when
you have this complete
collapse of law enforcement.
And then what "The Locust
Effect" tries to do
is then tell the
story of the violence
that this collapse has unleashed
for the poorest in the world.
And we go to four categories
of violence against the poor.
The first one is what
we call gender violence.
It's just sexual violence
and domestic abuse
against women and girls.
Which according to the
World Health Organization,
it accounts for more death
and disability in the world
than malaria, cancer,
car accidents, and war
all combined.
The greatest threat for
the average poor person
in the developing world,
especially a woman or a girl
is violence close at
home, sexual violence,
or domestic abuse.
I got to know a good
deal about this working
with International
Justice Mission which,
by the way, so grateful
for Google's partnership
in this work trying to protect
the poorest from violence.
And what we do is we have teams
in the developing world who
are local indigenous
nationals, and they
are lawyers, and
criminal investigators,
and social workers and they take
on these cases of violent abuse
and oppression on
behalf of the victims
and seek justice for them.
Make sure the perpetrators
are brought to justice,
and make sure that we
provide long-term care
for the survivors of this abuse.
And so now we've been doing
this for almost 20 years,
we've had 10s of thousands of
cases of this violent abuse.
And it's getting to
know those cases that
allows us to see the reality.
And it came on for me meeting
this woman, Lucilla in Peru.
Lucilla's a common
Andean mom who's
trying to provide for
her little family.
And as I got to know
her, I came to know
the story of living
in her little town,
she experienced the
horrific rape and murder
of her eight-year-old
girl who was just
dumped out on the street.
They didn't even have
the-- I don't know.
They didn't even
bother with the shame
of like throwing her in
the river or anything.
They just left her
out on the street.
And to follow Lucilla
on the journey
to see what it means
to try to get justice
for such a crime when you have
no functioning law enforcement.
One of things I found out
about Lucilla's little town
in the Andean mountains
is that it actually
had a higher rate of sexual
assault against women and girls
than what was coming out of the
worst war zones of the Congo.
And this was also
the idea that there
can be levels of
violence taking place
that maybe in the headlines
we hear about it when it's
in a war, or a
conflict, or a genocide,
but we're talking in this
book about everyday violence.
The second category of everyday
violence that afflicts the poor
is straight up slavery.
The global slavery index
just came out in October,
and it affirmed that there's
about 30 million people
in the world who are
literally held in slavery.
That's more people in slavery
than at any other time
in human history.
About 11 million people
were extracted from Africa
during 400 years of the
transatlantic slave trade.
But today, there's about
30 million held in slavery.
In the book, you get the
sort of up close view of this
from getting to know Mariama
and the story of her family
and a number of
other villagers who
were held as slaves
in a brick factory.
And this is not in some
completely remote lawless
part of India either.
This is really just on the
beltway outside Bangalore,
which is as you know
the high-tech capital
in many ways of India.
But it would just take
us a matter of minutes
before we could be able to
drive with investigators to be
able to find places
of literal slavery.
So that's the second category
of violence is slavery.
Third is the reality of police
abuse in the lives of the poor.
The World Bank did
this global study
which revealed that, it
said, police and courts
in the developing
world actually make
poor people less
secure and poorer.
What you find is that poor
people in the developing world
don't run to the police for
protection and to be safe.
They run from the police
to be protected and safe.
Statistics will also
show that the police are
likely to actually steal more
from a common poor person
than anybody else in
their community just
from the daily grind of
extortion and bribery.
So that's the fourth
category of violence.
I mean, the third.
The fourth is
violent land seizure,
the way that millions of
poor people every year
are threatened with having
their land stolen from them.
In fact, about 5 million a
year find themselves forcibly
thrown off their land.
One of the largest categories
of victims of land theft
are widows.
Widows like, Susan, who is
one our clients in Uganda.
And one of the things
we don't realize
is that widows in
the developing world
support about a half
a billion orphans.
And so if you throw that family
off their little plot of land
where they have
their little shelter,
and their little
garden, and they're
trying to sort of make
their way out of poverty,
you have just decimated
their capacity to go forward.
All of this I
emphasize is what we're
calling everyday violence.
Because many times when we
see or hear about violence,
it's the stuff that
makes the headlines,
the big wars, the genocide.
I know something about
the phenomena of genocide.
I was the Director of the UN's
genocide in Rwanda in 1994.
And my job was to sort through
about 100 different mass graves
and massacre sites to see
what it looks like when
human beings just unleash
violence against one another.
And the things that
you notice when
you're digging
through all of that,
and you trying to
picture what's it
like in the moment of
genocide to be in that place,
you realize that that person
in the moment of terror
is really not crying out
for someone to bring them
food, or a doctor, or a
teacher, or a microloan, right?
They're crying out for
someone to restrain
the hand of the
machete that's coming
towards them and their family.
And this is what
we are identifying
in terms of our
engagement with the poor.
We know a great deal about
providing food, and medicine,
and education, and
other basic needs,
but what about the violence?
And so this is an effort
through "The Locust Effect"
to begin to open our
eyes to this epidemic.
We're calling it
"The Locust Effect."
It comes from these
stories from history
that are very
powerful when you've
got these poor farmers who
were sort of starting to scrape
their way out of poverty, and
all of their work and ambition
is in their crops, right?
And they see them growing
and they offer great promise.
And then one day, the
locust just descend.
And honestly, in
a matter of hours,
they will just wipe
out years of work.
And this is the way violence
operates in the developing
world for the poor who are
trying to get out of poverty.
The violent predators just
come through and take it away.
And so this means there are
tremendous implications for all
of us who care about
global poverty.
Probably all of us in
our lifetime in some way
have been engaged with
that struggle, right?
We've given some money.
We've sought fresh water.
We've sponsored a child.
We've helped with
a school somewhere.
We sponsored a microloan.
And so all of these are
extremely important efforts,
and we've seen a lot
of significant progress
over the last 30 years
in addressing poverty.
But what we're
starting to see now
is we may be reaching
the limit of what
can be done if we
don't begin to address
the locust of violence who
can come in and just sweep
the benefits of all
that effort away.
The thing you'll notice
about the locust as well,
is that not only do the
locust descend and destroy
the fruit of the
farmer, but the farmer
is not going to stop the locust.
Right?
We have to actually start
to do something differently.
And so that's what "The
Locust Effect" is trying to do
is to begin to change the
conversation about poverty
to make sure that
we're mainstreaming
the problem of violence.
Because if that's
off the radar screen,
we're going to miss
out on something that's
undermining all
of our good work.
One of the things that
the book tries to do
is to try to say, well, why
is law enforcement so broken
in the developing world?
Why is there such
a lawless chaos
for the average poor person?
The book brings forth
really three surprises,
and then one thing
that's not so surprising.
The first surprise
is to realize, oh,
all of these law enforcement
systems in the developing
world, they were never
designed to stop crime.
They were never designed to
protect the common poor person
from violence.
They were set up by colonial
powers over the first stage
of the 20th century in order
to protect the government
from the common people.
And they've never been
re-engineered to actually
enforce the law.
And as a result, poor people
in the developing world
now have great laws.
This tremendous human rights
revolution over the last 50
years has embedded great
laws in these countries.
But what they don't
have is law enforcement.
And it turns out that
that really matters.
And mostly because
they've been saddled
with these colonial
systems of law enforcement
that have never
been re-engineered.
The second reason
you find out is
that there's been a massive
privatization of security
in the developing world.
So if you've been traveling in
the developing world at all,
you'll sort of maybe notice,
especially in your first visit
there, like almost
everywhere I go
somebody's got a
gun guarding us.
I mean, he's at the
restaurant, at the hotel,
they're at the whatever sort
of commercial enterprise.
There are just people
providing physical protection
all the time.
I was at the World
Economic Forum at Davos
a few years ago with a
number of corporate leaders
who have massive investments
in the developing
world, huge
facilities, thousands
and thousands of employees.
And I just asked with all this
violence in the developing
world that we're aware of,
like how do you guys protect
your people and your property?
And they all kind of
look at each other,
and they actually almost
answer in unison to say,
we pay for it.
But if you think
about this, it's
one thing if those with
wealth and influence
leave the public school and the
public school kind of gets bad.
Or you leave the public
transportation system,
and the buses
become not so great.
But what happens when the
people of wealth and power
abandon the public
justice system?
When the basic law
enforcement system
is allowed to get worse,
and worse, and worse?
That is the reality in
the developing world.
And part of the
reason it stayed off
the radar screen of
everybody is that the sector
of wealthy folks in the
developing world from whom
the economic growth
is coming from,
have been able to
secure themselves
with private security.
And so now, in the aggregate,
if you look at that country,
it produces a decent
rate of economic growth.
But for people who are living
off, let's say, $2 a day,
that's about more
than 2 billion people,
those folks can afford to
be safe and so they're not.
The third other
surprising reason
behind sort of the
brokenness of law enforcement
is it's just not been the
subject of our investment.
We've poured trillions of
dollars over the last 50 years
into food systems, water
systems, public health systems,
all totally vital, and
actually we haven't necessarily
spent enough on trying
to engage those systems,
because the poor need
all of those things.
But we can't find even 1% of
all that expenditure and effort
over the last 50 years that has
gone to building public justice
systems that will actually
protect the poor from violence.
So the third surprise is to
say, oh, we haven't actually
really tried all that hard
to address this problem yet.
The fourth explanation is
less surprising, perhaps,
and that's just
the idea that there
are people in power in
the developing world who
have figured out how to
succeed in the absence
of public justice, right?
And so they now actually
would feel quite threatened
if justice systems actually
started working in the way
that they should.
So that's the
diagnosis that we're
trying to make here in
"The Locust Effect,"
but then we try to make
a turn towards hope.
And that is to
ask, OK great, this
is totally depressing,
massive violence, grotesque.
There's no way I'm
going to read this book.
I'm depressed already.
My wife is like,
yeah, give me a gin
and tonic the next
time I'm going
to try to read one
of your books, Gary.
So yeah, the bad news is true.
But this is part of where the
good news comes from, right?
Because if you
think about the era
when the AIDS
epidemic was really
beginning to catch
momentum in the world,
it required everybody to
open their eyes to something
that was still a little
beneath the surface,
but if unaddressed was
going to roll over just
about everything else.
And that's where we
are when it comes
to the phenomenon of violence
in the developing world.
So yes, we've got to wake up
to what is the tough reality.
But the hope can be found
in a number of areas.
The first is just in history.
The truth is all of us enjoy
reasonably functioning justice
systems here in New York, or you
can be in the San Francisco Bay
Area, or Chicago, or you're
around the world in Paris
or Tokyo, or various places
around the world that
have the more developed
and affluent economies.
And in each one of
those cities, you
will find a history where 100
years ago, 150 years ago, you
would have had the exact
same levels of just
horrific violence and
horrific police corruption
and brutality.
In the book, we give
actually a series
of descriptions to ask you,
like, guess which city this is?
And you think your reading
from some just nightmare
of a city in the
developing world,
but actually it's one of
the cities that we live in.
And you can see,
oh, every country
begins with a difficult
situation of lawless violence,
and you need to build systems
to protect the common citizenry.
So what is the
process by which you
move to law enforcement
that actually
protects the common person?
And you learn that this is
actually quite a doable thing.
So you learn these
lessons from history
and some clues about what might
happen in the developing world,
but also some very
specific projects
that we have highlighted in
the book where the success is
really very encouraging
that if you focus on helping
law enforcement do its job,
it has a dramatic result.
One of those projects we did
in the second largest city
of the Philippines
called Cebu which
had a horrible problem
of child sex trafficking.
The abduction and taking
of these young minor girls
into the commercial
sex industry,
and it's just a business
of rape for profit.
And this was just taking
place at a horrific level
in the city of Cebu.
And we got some funding
from the Gates Foundation
to try and experiment.
Let's see whether or not it's
possible to do two things.
Number one, let's see if
we can actually stand up
local law enforcement,
which when we first
began the project in the
city, it was actually
on almost on the side of
sex trafficking, right?
They're actually protecting
this and receiving funding
for doing so.
And by the way, the people
who carried out this project
were our local
Filipino staff, right?
Local Filipino lawyers,
Filipino criminal investigators,
and social workers, and they
were trying to do two things.
One, can we stand up that
local law enforcement
through training and
programs of empowerment
that allow them
to actually begin
to send sex traffickers to jail?
And if we do that,
will it actually
then lower the amount
of sex trafficking
of kids in the city?
So we had some outside auditors
come in at the beginning
and measure, well, how
much victimization of kids
is there in the sex trade
before the project even begins.
And then let's measure
it four years later
to see what the impact is.
So four years training
law enforcement,
setting up specialized
units, fast tracking courts,
providing good social
services to the victim,
so they could actually make
their way through the justice
system and receive healing.
So after rescuing
hundreds of those victims
and then sending about hundred
of the traffickers to jail,
what was the outcome
after four years?
The goal of the
project was to try
to achieve a 20% reduction
in the victimization of kids
in the commercial sex trade.
But after four years, the
auditors came back and measured
and they found a 79% reduction
in the victimization of kids
in the commercial sex trade.
And what you find is that
those who brutalize the poor,
and children especially,
are not brave people.
They're doing it
because they can.
And once they start
getting in trouble for it,
they start to leave the
children and the kids alone.
So this is sort of the reality
that we're helping people
to recover through the book.
That, yes, there's a real
serious problem in the world,
but there's really
hopeful possibilities
for making a difference.
I would, of course, say that
the real purpose of this book
is to begin to change the
conversation about poverty,
right?
Because if you
enter a discussion
about global
poverty, if you think
of the phenomenon
of yourself, you
think of, OK, food and hunger.
You think of medical care.
You think of shacks.
You think of bad
sanitation, bad education,
the need for microloans,
all that sort of thing.
But what does not
generally come to our mind
is the violence that the poor
are chronically vulnerable to.
And we just want to
change that conversation
to make sure we're
asking the question, what
about the violence?
So we would like you to be
a part of that for sure.
We'd love for you to buy
the book, first of all.
Educate yourself, share
it with other people.
If you buy the book
this week, we actually
have some donors that
are going to match
that with a $20 contribution
towards the actual work
in the field of trying to defend
those who are victims of abuse.
We'll have a copy here.
And Victor Boutros
who's my co-author,
I always want to recognize him.
Victor Boutros.
We're happy to sign
those, and that
will add $0.4 to the value
of the book or something.
So we would love for you to
buy the book and to share that.
The second thing
we'd like to do is
actually, have you look
at a piece of video
that we've put together to
likewise share on social media.
Because obviously,
we've written this book,
it's got 40 pages of footnotes.
It really takes you into sort
of the deep intellectual case
about what's going on.
But for most of
us, in many ways,
it's important just for us
to get a heart level almost
sense of what this
challenge is looking
like for the common person,
and also what the promise is.
So if you've got two
minutes, let's have
a look at this
video, and then talk
about one more thing
we can do together.
[VIDEO PLAYING]
So that's the second
thing we'd love you to do,
just help get the
conversation going
by sharing that piece of video.
The third thing, is that right
now at the United Nations,
there's a tremendously
important conversation
taking place related to the
Millennium Development Goals.
In the year 2000, the
international community
came together to build sort
of the definitive roadmap
for addressing poverty, and they
set out these eight Millennium
Development Goals.
And they've been pursuing
them over the last 15 years,
and have seen some really
significant progress
on those targeted things.
The big problem that people
are starting to realize,
though, is that they spoke
of the massive solution
to try to deal with
poverty, and they did not
say a word about violence.
And now, imagine you're trying
to move the world forward out
of poverty, but you're
not doing anything
about this violence
that is just ripping
the rug out from underneath
everyone's ability
to move forward.
So we have a petition that
we're putting together
and there's a way to sign
on there that will just
be going to the UN team that
is starting to put together
the Millennium Development Goals
to say, hey, let's just make
sure that this conversation
includes addressing
the violence that is descending
like locusts upon the poor
in developing world.
This is, again, from the
AIDS epidemic perspective,
it wasn't just the
public health experts.
It wasn't just the sort
of global affairs experts
that rang the alarm
about the problem,
and said, no, this is
something we need to address.
It was very, very
common people who
began to think differently
about the problems in the world
and to make sure that we were
addressing this epidemic as
well.
And I think it's an
opportunity for all of us
to raise our voice
on behalf of those
who are victims of
violence as well.
So thank you very much
for the opportunity
to let me drone on here a bit,
but I would love to-- I've
been trying to guess about
what, if any of this,
might be interesting to you.
But it, actually, might
be better to ask you.
So what questions do you have?
How might we engage the
conversation together?
And I understand from Justin,
unlike his prior advertisements
to me, I don't
actually get to be
able to hear from
the folks remotely.
So you guys carry all
the burden of asking
the engaging and good questions.
So here you go.
What are thoughts, questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The question
is two for one.
When you collected help like
[INAUDIBLE] and everything
you mentioned, do we expect--
does that decrease violence
in those countries
that [INAUDIBLE]
and by which factor?
And two.
This experiment that
you did in the city
with the sex trafficking,
how much did it cost and can
you put a price
[INAUDIBLE] on this program
compared to if you had given
meals, and food, and whatever,
what the benefits are.
GARY A. HAUGEN:
Yeah, great question.
Sort of going at the first one,
I mean, the second one first.
The data on the actual
cost of law enforcement
is available to us.
It'll give you an idea
of what it would cost.
The data is not very good about
how much the economic benefit
is from all of that.
And so it's just being
very much developed.
But what you can
see, for instance,
is that where the
studies have been done,
the GDP is reduced
somewhere between 2% and 7%
an entire nation by criminal
violence and violence
in the community.
You will see, in they did some
studies in Latin America where
they showed half of the
accumulated net social capital
was eliminated, half of it
over a 15-year period of time
because of violence.
They're starting
to begin to develop
the numerical costs of violence.
It costs for instance in what
they call Disability Adjusted
Life Years, about 9 million
Disability Adjusted life years
are wasted because of violence
against women and girls.
And so that's massive
amounts of productivity.
What you also know is that the
economies that are actually
producing social mobility
are the ones that
provide protection for
those who are poorest.
Because in the absence
of that, they're
unable to keep even the
benefits of their effort.
Some of this is hard to see,
though, because in, as I
explained a little bit, in
low income and middle income
countries right
now, you actually
see some significant rates of
economic growth, reasonable GDP
advancements.
But what you see when you
look at it, and disaggregate
it is that that
economic growth is
coming from the sector
of the country that
has protected itself
with private security.
And that's a massive
expense, by the way, that
could be poured into a public
security, but at the moment
is just privatizing part of it.
One of things that the book does
is call for much greater study
of how much would this cost?
What would the benefit be?
But there certainly is now
enough data from the World Bank
and from other multilateral
institutions that
suggest that what is lost
to violence is massive.
And that if we don't get out in
front of it, that kind of cost
is just going to grow.
Yeah.
Other questions?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So the
first question was
people are looking at is from
an economic modeling standpoint.
Are people looking at it
also from a public health
standpoint?
Because the models
might be different.
And the other question was,
I'm curious about the-- I mean,
solving this at the macro
level seems very hard, right?
Because you have civil societies
that may not have traditions,
and they differ radically.
So I'd like you to talk
a little bit about that.
Perfect.
GARY A. HAUGEN: Thank you.
Yeah, certainly this has, over
just maybe the last 15 years,
been looked at now as an
epidemiological matter
from the public health sector.
In fact, the World Health
Organization, it was about 10,
15 years ago now, did
this massive global study
about violence as
a health problem.
And that's where much
of the data for the book
is now coming from is the
World Health Organization
and public health
experts are dialed
into sort of the implications,
the ripple effects, of violence
in the lives of poor people.
What public health
has no experience in,
however, is how you
stop the violence.
And what is then
unfortunate is that world
of law enforcement that actually
reduces violent behavior is
sort of then off in its
own silo and public health
has been off in its silo.
And what we're
encouraging now is
that those things come together.
There's been some work done
on the economics of violence
and the way that
undermines economic growth.
But most of that's been
done in developed countries.
So obviously, the data's
easier and more available,
and it's a little
too bad the way
our study tends to
run to the places
where the examination of
the problem is easiest.
That makes sense in a
certain kind of way,
but we do need to bring
a lot of those lenses
now into the developing
world to fully appreciate
what's happening.
The other question
is absolutely the one
to be answered, which
is, wow, this just
sounds like this massive generic
problem that actually is very
localized in its manifestations,
and probably in its solutions,
how do we begin to address it?
One of our suggestions
in the book
is precisely that what is
needed are some small scale
experiments in some focused
places in the world.
It's true, for instance, that
penicillin works everywhere
in the world.
And there are
certain ways in which
law enforcement
works everywhere.
As to say, in almost
every context,
if human beings face a
cost for doing a behavior,
they are reduced in their
likelihood of doing it.
That's just true the same way
that penicillin just works.
But what it takes in a
given society and culture
for law enforcement
to be effective
and to be supported
by the community,
that's a different
equation everywhere.
So we're interested
in supporting,
and actually are
pursuing now, we
have seven different
projects around the world,
like the Cebu one,
which says, OK,
not everywhere and in
regard to everything,
but let's start in
a few laboratories
and begin to experiment.
What does it take in order
to do one thing first,
stand up local law enforcement?
Have the police, and the courts,
and the public justice system
actually switch sides.
So that instead of
preying upon the poor,
they're actually
protecting the poor.
And we've actually learned
quite a bit about that.
And there's some
things you see that are
common in most communities.
And there's other things
that are very particular.
And so what there
needs to be is just
a much more robust
experimentation
of this in the world.
Because again, it's not going
to come from a silver bullet
one size fits all.
We did here in America, so
it's going to work over here.
It's going to be a customized,
tailor-made, and community
owned struggle in order to
bring justice for the poor.
But that's when we need to start
to bring resources and effort
to that's commensurate to
the size of the problem.
Thank you.
Other questions?
Please, Justin.
AUDIENCE: So being
that we are at Google,
I'm curious as to what your
thoughts are on the role
that technology
can play in being
a constructive element
of these changes.
GARY A. HAUGEN: Yeah,
well, one of things
I'm hoping technology
will do is just sort
of shrink the world in
terms of awareness, right?
Because one of the things that's
difficult in this era is we
can live on different
planetary systems, right?
I mean, the idea that there are
millions of people in slavery.
The idea that sexual assault
can take place at such a level
that you're more likely
to fall in the shower
than to ever go to jail for it.
Those can feel so far from us.
And one of the things
that this era has done
is shrink that world
so that everyone
can be much more aware of this.
One of things that we're
also starting to bring
is visualization of this.
I mean, our teams now do
undercover investigations
that expose these kinds of
abuses that are taking place.
And that stuff can now
almost be shared real time
around the world.
It's going to be
harder and harder
to get away with this stuff.
But once we have
exposure, then we
need to move actually
towards solutions.
The other thing that technology
has a capacity to do,
amazingly, is bring
accountability
and transparency.
You're starting to see this
in the corruption realm
now where instead
of paying a police
officer for your ticket on
the spot, you go to some kiosk
somewhere electronically
and pay for that.
So it isn't even the opportunity
for the police officer
to take the money.
Or to like be able to
go to register and say,
yeah, there were supposed to
be police in our community,
and if this is day 20 where
we've never seen anybody,
and all that sort of data and
that picture starts to appear.
So we're even exploring the ways
in which satellite imagery is
able to actually see
where the brick kilns are
in South Asia where there's
more likely to be slavery.
And the tracking of
criminality, the new VP
of investigations at IJM is
the former director of NCIS.
And he's very interested in
trying to leverage technology
in this crime fighting
effort around the world.
So I'm not the one,
certainly, to be
able to suggest what all
the possibilities are,
but what I would love to
do is to see those who have
this expertise and these
capacities just sort of join
the struggle and the fight.
Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: Just as an idea,
with the proliferation
of cell phones
throughout the world.
What about the self-reporting?
GARY A. HAUGEN: Absolutely.
Yeah, you do notice
that right now.
There are very few
bad things that
happen these days sort of in any
kind of public way, especially
law enforcement and so
forth that there aren't
five people around
with a cell phone.
Challenge, of course, in
the poorest communities
is the people living off $2 a
day have less access to that.
And to be clear,
you can see why this
is why crime runs to
those places, right?
It runs to be amongst
the poor, because they're
going to be the least empowered.
One of things we
do, of course, is
take that kind of technology
into those communities
and into some of the darkest
places where crime is taking
place, infiltrate it
with video technology,
and now the world can see
and know what's going on.
And that is, you have
to know, that when
you think about violent
perpetrators of horrific crime,
they just seem so intimidating,
and how could you ever
go against them?
One of the things you have to
understand about criminality
and violence is that there's
a reason why they hide it,
because they're afraid.
You fundamentally
hide what you're
doing, because you're afraid
that if somebody saw it,
you would be in trouble, and
you couldn't get away with it.
And as our world has the
technology increasingly
for where the bullies cannot
do this without being seen,
they're going to do it less.
So there's significant promise.
The question now I
think, substantially,
is how to get those
tools increasingly
in the hands of those
who are poorest.
Daniel, did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you we're
talking about experiments.
I know that there have been a
number of things on experiments
in trying to [INAUDIBLE]
poverty like the team of MIT.
Can we work with them?
And can you describe some
of your other projects?
GARY A. HAUGEN:
Yeah, no, we haven't
had the opportunity of
the poverty lab at MIT
that actually did a
really fantastic project
with Indian police
to actually see
what it would take for the
community to actually begin
to have greater confidence
in working with the police.
And it's like all
great resources,
a set of things that are
confirmed by the data
that, oh yeah, we really did
think that that would help.
And then also turns
out, nope, everybody
thought this would help.
Doesn't help at all.
So we would love to
have an opportunity
to engage some of our work
with that kind of very
careful sort of
measurement capacity.
Because that's what's
it's going to take.
It's going to be
sort of taking what
we think we know about improving
these law enforcement systems,
and then testing it, and
measuring, and seeing what
actually does work and let's
put more resources on the things
actually work.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked about violence
as contributing
cause to poverty.
GARY A. HAUGEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What about the
causes of the violence itself?
How much of that is,
perhaps, need driven?
GARY A. HAUGEN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it cultural?
Is it innate?
Does mankind just suck?
A very small
percentage of people
having a very large
impact on the community,
or can you discuss
violence as an effect?
GARY A. HAUGEN: I'd love to.
I will tell you,
any of you who'd
taken a genocide course
in college or something
and look at genocide, I
mean, it's disturbing.
The capacity for the
very common person
to become very, very violent
in regard to their neighbors
is amazing.
And as the investigator
of the Rwanda genocide,
the story is there that once
the restraints were taken off,
and you could do
anything to your neighbor
to take their land, to
sexually assault the neighbor's
daughter, and to
kill your neighbor,
this is unleashed with
quite frightening ferocity.
So there is something
in human beings
that just needs to
be accounted for.
And we've seen in history, too,
that the way that most violence
is restrained is
by law enforcement.
That's why we all
have law enforcement.
None of you are choosing to
live in a neighborhood that
has no law enforcement.
But it would be interesting,
and if I had a whiteboard here,
you could draw a graph of crime.
And on the left axis, you
would put different kinds
of crime and their frequency.
And then what you
do is draw a line
on the horizontal axis of risk.
And what you would
measure is sort
of the elasticity of different
kinds of crime to risk.
And at the top is what we
call crime of opportunity.
You do it because you
can get away with it,
and there's no risk at all.
And so you do it
because you can.
Then there's crime
of desperation.
Maybe I'm poor, and I feel
like I got a break that window
and steal that bread, because
I'm really quite desperate.
Then there's crime of necessity.
You feel like in order to hold
power, or in order to survive,
you must commit this crime.
And sometimes when the state
commits crime, like torture,
they feel like they
have to do this, right?
It's necessity.
And then if you go way
down towards the bottom,
you have social
pathology and deviancy.
A person actually can't
even stop themselves
from committing that
crime, because there's
a sickness involved.
All of those have different
elasticity to risk.
So the pathology, man, somebody
who's really a social deviant,
and you see this with
pedophilia and other-- there you
can actually ratchet
up to risk level.
And it drops maybe a little
bit, but that line actually
stays pretty steady,
because in that they end up
going to jail in many
respects if there's decent law
enforcement.
Then you have
crime of necessity,
and likewise, it
takes a little dip,
but then it stays
pretty steady, too.
Desperation, yeah, it
takes a fall a little bit,
but when desperation
feels like necessity,
it also flattens out.
But crime of
opportunity, amazing.
That stuff goes out
a little bit by risk,
and then it drops off to
zero, because it was crime
because I could
get away with it.
Now I can't get away with it,
I'm just not doing any more.
The vast, vast, vast majority
of violence against the poor
is crime of opportunity.
And so we can with law
enforcement reduce that amount,
and then we'll be wrestling
with the kind of crime
that we're dealing with in our
more developed countries, which
is the hard problems of
social deviancy and people
who are desperate and have
no hope, all kinds of things
involved here, substance abuse
and a whole set of factors
But all this crime
of opportunity, this
is where all the crime is
happening against the poor
because they can.
And that is a very,
very doable proposition.
Long lecture on the
elasticity of crime
than you weren't
expecting today.
I apologize in advance.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What about the
real structural situation
of just the police and underpay?
And the fact that in many
countries being a cop
is a license to steal.
GARY A. HAUGEN: Absolutely.
Yeah.
So that has to be addressed.
That's the bad news.
The good news is it's
totally addressable.
In other words, it's not
rocket science in a way.
I worked the first
half of my career,
and Victor currently is that
the US Department of Justice
dealing with police corruption.
So in every society,
you are going
to have police corruption,
but it actually
turns out there's things
that you can do about this.
And one of the case studies
that we look at in the book
is the study of the
country of Georgia,
which is a former
Soviet Republic.
And it was one of the most
corrupt countries in the world.
In fact, in 2003,
Transparency International
ranked it as like 143
out of a 190 countries
in being the most corrupt.
I mean, more corrupt
than any country
that we currently work in.
And we work in some
very corrupt countries.
And yet there was a
political election,
a party was committed
to a platform, really
of anti-corruption
came into power.
And they seriously went after
police corruption first.
Just to give you an idea,
police corruption in Georgia,
you would pay $10,000 to
the police commissioner
in order to get hired as a
police officer for which you
are paid $10.
Why would you pay
$10,000 for a job that
was only going to
pay to $10 a month?
It's because you were
given a license really
to use that authority
then to steal from people.
And what happened as a
result, is the state just
started producing more and
more police officers, right?
Because I get this now.
The more police officers
there are, the more money
I make as the
commissioner of police.
As far as payment, let
me just address that.
So what they did is they
came in very committed
to addressing this.
The thing they did is they
fired 16,000 police officers
in a single day in the capital.
Sent them all
home, and the place
was safer and better for it.
Right?
Just sent them all
home and rebuilt
the police from the ground up.
One of the things
that they had to do
was then pay the
police very well,
because they want to
recruit good people,
and equip them well,
and supply them well.
And as a result a lot of this
committed effort, by 2010
seven years later, the
Georgian police force
was rated as less corrupt
than the US police,
the German police,
or the French police.
The World Bank wrote
up the study of this,
and it's featured in the book.
Because I actually
fortuitously sat next
to the prime
minister of Georgia,
because I was amazed
at this story.
And I got a chance to talk
to him over dinner about it.
And he said people say
that corruption is culture.
He says, corruption is a choice.
And when a society
makes the choice
to begin to root this
out, it's possible.
And the place to start
amazingly is the police,
because it sounds
counterintuitive in a way,
because that's like the
worst, scariest place.
But if you think about
it, corruption is a crime.
It's stealing from other people.
And if you have crime of
corruption in the crime
fighting force, your capacity
to root it out from other places
is just about zero.
So we've kind of laughed
about it and joked about it.
Oh, the police are corrupt
in the developing world.
No, no, that's a
serious problem,
because that has
undermined your capacity
to deal with any
corruption in your country.
And so that's the bad news.
The good news is, because
this is a command structure,
leadership can
actually change that
quite quickly if there's
commitment from the top.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You make a
sensible point, right?
We buy the story and everything.
Why [INAUDIBLE], they have
the money and everything,
why nothing has happened?
GARY A. HAUGEN:
Yeah, Great question,
which is why isn't
everybody already
addressing this already?
That's a hard question, too.
And actually, I've spent the
last 10 years going around
to almost every
smart person I can.
Because as they started
to come to our eyes
from just the daily work in the
developing world, it's like,
hey, isn't this
is a big problem,
and isn't this just
going to get worse,
and don't we need to
get out in front of it?
There are some reasons why
it's been very difficult.
One of the reasons
is that the people
who are immersed in
the academic and sort
of technical disciplines
of fighting poverty
are just very foreign to the
world of law enforcement,
right?
So it's the economist, the
agronomist, the clean water
engineers, the
public health folks.
What it takes to actually
do a highly effective law
enforcement is a completely
different discipline.
So these worlds have
been very far apart,
and we're trying to
bring them together.
The second thing is that
it's been dangerous and scary
for aid organizations to engage
supporting law enforcement
in the developing world,
because law enforcement is not
a benign system.
Right?
Because it's a coercive system.
It's the coercive arm of the
state, and if it turns bad,
it commits abuses.
Now you helped empower
it, and you're like, oh,
now we're in trouble for that.
So we actually made
illegal after human rights
abuses in the 70s and
80s for aid organizations
to assist police.
Now it seemed like a good
idea to like stop the abuses,
but the answer to
bad law enforcement
is not going to be
no law enforcement.
So we need to say,
yeah, there's a bad way
to assist law enforcement.
But they're also clearly
now some good ways to do it,
and that's what
we need to pursue.
Thanks again for your
patience and interest.
And please buy the book,
and share the video,
and help us change the
discussion on the Millennium
Development Goals.
Thanks very much.